[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen an diesem
montag was im sport passiert ist das
erfahren sie von norbert lehmann beim
gegentor von mir gerade ist das treffen
zu dem corona maßnahmen des kanzlers mit
dem ministerpräsidenten und präsidenten
zu ende gegangen wir schauen darauf was
rausgekommen ist
reaktion auf instanzen im tausender
bereich bund und länder wollen
deutschland vorerst ohne lockerungen
durch die omikron welle steuer
szene zeigen in richtung moskau mehrere
nato-staaten erhöhen wegen der ukraine
krise ihre militärpräsenz in osteuropa
und schock an der uni heidelberg ein
bewaffneter mann erschießt in einem
hörsaal eine frau und verletzt weitere
dann tötet er sich selbst
keine verschärfung aber auch keine
lockerungen bei den corona maßnahmen das
ist kurz zusammengefasst das ergebnis
des bund länder treffen es heute schauen
wir uns genau an was entschieden wurde
änderungen gibt es etwa bei den
zunehmend knappen pcr tests bevorzugt
werden nun wohl der a baugruppen sowie
krankenhaus- und pflegepersonal alle
anderen verdachtsfälle sollen wie es
heißt überwachte hochwertige
schnelltests nutzen auch bei der kontakt
nach verfolgung soll es nun
priorisierungen geben über weitere
beschlüsse und über offene fragen dann
getanzt
frage 1 ändert sich wesentliches an den
bisherigen maßnahmen nein keine
verschärfungen keine lockerungen den
grundsätzlichen kurs behalte man bei
dies die kurzfristige botschaft heute
die langfristige impfen bleibe zentral
dazu plane man eine neue kampagne über
sämtliche medialen plattformen wir
versuchen auch in viele zielgruppen
hineinzukommen der oberen bürger zu
erreichen die bisher von den
verschiedenen informations aktivitäten
nicht erreicht worden denn es gilt wie
oben drauf steht impfung hilft zudem
widmete man sich folgender frage können
menschen auch künftig kurzfristig ihren
zweig status verlieren jüngst geschah
dies vielen genesenen und johnson
geimpften die zuständigen institute
hatten die voraussetzungen kurzfristig
geändert und länder hatten sie dazu
autorisiert dies bleibt so allerdings
sollten künftige änderungen laut vorlage
rechtzeitig vor ihrem inkrafttreten
angekündigt und begründet werden mit
einem vorlauf von zwei wochen solche
änderungen brauchen einen angemessenen
vorlauf die menschen müssen sich darauf
auch ein stück vorbereiten können keiner
vorausschauenden pandemie politik gerät
eben auch verlässlichkeit neue fragen
knüpften sich unterdessen an die
priorisierung bei den pcr tests vor
allem was bedeutet die priorisierung für
betroffene die keinen pcr-test mehr
machen können gelten sich nach einer
infektion als genesen auch ohne pc
ergebnis und was wenn positive
schnelltest sich im nachhinein als
falsch herausstellen wenig aufklärung
hierzu heute vorab vom ministerium die
fragen die sie stellen das sind das sind
wichtige fragen für die für die
bürgerinnen und bürger und auch die
frage welche das welche auswirkungen das
dann am ende hat aber ich bitte um
nachsicht das sind alles detail fragen
die wir auch im rahmen der test
verordnung dann dann klären werden eine
öffnung perspektive hieß es derweil
würden bund und länder entwickeln für
den moment zudem eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems ausgeschlossen werden
könne
theo koll für uns in berlin beim treffen
gab es ja auch streit vorüber und es gab
gleich doppelt so viele
ministerpräsidenten waren ziemlich sauer
über den bundesgesundheitsminister weil
der genießen den status vieler menschen
quasi über nacht verändert worden war
und die länderchefs darüber nicht wir
eigentlich versprochen rechtzeitig
informiert worden deshalb hat man karl
lauterbach jetzt auferlegt dass er
künftig rechtzeitig und zwar zwei wochen
vorher über änderungen informiert und es
gab eher politischen streit darüber wer
für die nicht ausreichend vorhandenen
pcr-test kapazitäten verantwortliches
also karl lauterbach oder noch sein
vorgänger jens spahn auch eine
allgemeine impfpflicht war ja thema
wurde sich dazu geäußert und der kanzler
hat offensichtlich das angebot von
ministerpräsident wüst angenommen sich
mit den ländern abzustimmen über die
mögliche allgemeine impfpflicht da gibt
es ja noch immer sehr unterschiedliche
vorstellungen selbst innerhalb der ampel
koalition aber am ende muss ja jeder
bundestagsbeschluss auch durch den
bundesrat und deshalb scheint es eine
rechtzeitige abstimmung mit den ländern
scheint sehr sinnvoll zu sein schon um
möglichen zeitverzug zu vermeiden denn
die impfpflicht soll ja rechtzeitig für
impfungen noch vor der nächsten virus
wähle dann gelten vielen dank für diese
einordnung theo koll in berlin
und gleich nach dieser sendung können
sie ein zdf spezial sehen mit dem
schwerpunkt zwei jahre corona und kein
ende außerdem finden sie alle
entwicklungen zur corona pandemie in
deutschland und weltweit im live-blog in
unserer zdf heute
blicken wir jetzt auf die aktuellen
corona zahlen die zahl der
neuinfektionen hat sich im vergleich zur
vorwoche fast verdoppelt dem robert koch
institut wurden 63
1393 neue fälle gemeldet das sind 29
1248 mehr als am vergangenen montag
28 menschen starben binnen eines tages
im zusammenhang mit komik 19 die sieben
tage incident steigt auf 8 140,3
noch höher sind die inzidenz werte in
etlichen stadt und landkreisen und da
sticht besonders eine metropole hervor
berlin nirgendwo in deutschland sind die
zahlen höher als im bezirk mitte die
inzidenz dort
2842 und es weit leichter hinter folgen
vier weitere bezirke mit werten über
1700 die folge personalausfälle das ist
bereits spürbar beim öffentlichen
nahverkehr etwa gibt es schon
einschränkungen romanesco war
jetzt ist auch die u bahn betroffen die
berliner verkehrsbetriebe dünnen seit
heute früh die taktfrequenz weiter aus
die einschränkungen noch überschaubar
trotzdem immer mehr bereiche der
kritischen infrastruktur melden
personalausfall auch die polizei
pandemie stufe eins wurde ausgerufen
heißt 15 prozent der belegschaft fehlen
der anteil der korona betroffenen wächst
rasant in einem zeitraum von gut vier
wochen kurz vor weihnachten bis heute
haben sich die zeit knapp vervierfacht
lienz krankenhäuser sehen zwar
rückläufige zahlen auf den
intensivstationen dafür aber mehr cupid
patienten in der übrigen versorgung noch
geht es genug personal hoffnungen
richten sich auf die geänderten regeln
zur quarantäne
denn die betreffe nicht nur die
belegschaft selbst unsere beschäftigten
müssen auch selbst angehörige zu hause
in quarantäne betreuenden kinder
insgesamt macht die personalsituation
schon sorge die politik sprach vor
kurzem von berlinweit 15 prozent
ausfallquote in betrieben der kritischen
infrastruktur ein ampelsystem von grün
bis rot soll helfen die lage besser zu
überschauen wir haben die ampel auf gelb
wenn es einschränkungen im niedrigen
bereich gibt dort liegen fast alle
bereiche im moment und es würde dann zu
erheblichen oder kritischen
einschränkungen dann in den roten
bereich gehen wir sind nicht im roten
bereich wegen der infektionen gibt es
jetzt neuerungen auch an berlins schulen
am nachmittag wurde die präsenzpflicht
bis zunächst ende februar ausgesetzt das
heißt eltern können entscheiden ob sie
ihre kinder in den unterricht schicken
oder zu hause behalten
überraschende wende im skandal um
sexualisierte gewalt in der katholischen
kirche der emeritierte papst benedikt
der sechzehnte hat zugegeben eine
falsche aussage im gutachten zu den
vorgänger märz bistum münchen und
freising gemacht zu haben er sei doch
1980 bei einer umstrittenen sitzung
dabei gewesen bei der es um einen
geistlichen gegen der kinder sexuell
missbraucht hatte benedikt sprach von
einem fehler und einem versehen bei der
redaktionellen bearbeitung seiner
stellungnahme stefan leifert in münchen
welche reaktion gibt es darauf
die reaktionen könnten verheerend da
eigentlich nicht sein und sie erinnern
in ihrer wortwahl er an politische
skandale das höchste katholische
laiengremium zum beispiel spricht von
salamitaktik die reformbewegung maria
2.0 fordert joseph ratzinger heute auf
seinen papst namen abzugeben und ein
katholischer bischof aus deutschland
spricht benedikt indirekt die
vorbildfunktion ab was fast alle eint
ist die enttäuschung darüber dass
benedikt auch in seiner heutigen
erklärung keinerlei verantwortung
übernommen hat pabst verteidiger gibt es
nicht mehr viele aber auch regensburgs
bischof
beispielsweise sieht in der
veröffentlichung dieses gutachtens im
zeitpunkt der veröffentlichung auch in
der kritik an benedikt eine kampagne der
heutige tag zeigt unter dem strich
zweierlei zum einen wie sehr benedikt in
der defensive steht und derzeit zweitens
dass benedikt bei seiner strategie
bleibt im kirchen juristischen
klein-klein immer nur das zuzugeben was
nicht mehr zu leugnen ist und das deutet
schon an in welchen duktus auch seine
große erklärung die für die nächsten
wochen angekündigt ist sein dürfte von
übernahme von verantwortung oder gar
schuldeingeständnis ist benedikt
jedenfalls weit entfernt
danke für die einschätzung stefan
leifert
schauen wir jetzt auf den ukraine
konflikt mehrere nato-staaten wollen
zusätzliche kampftruppen nach osteuropa
verlegen sie befürchten einen einmarsch
russlands in die ukraine der kreml wies
das zurück und wird wiederum der nato
eine verschärfung der lage vor in
brüssel beraten die eu außenministerin
und minister heute zusammen mit den usa
darüber wie sie die ukraine unterstützen
können anne gellinek mit den
einzelheiten
die usa senden klare botschaften 90
tonnen militärische fracht für die
ukraine darunter munition außerdem
sollen die familien amerikanischer
diplomaten kiel verlassen die
europäischen außenminister sind
vorsichtiger sie wollen die lage nicht
weiter anheizen noch seien keine
evakuierungen von botschaftspersonal
geplant bei einer video schalte mit dem
amerikanischen außenminister blinken
versucht die eu ein bild der
geschlossenheit abzugeben und doch sind
die minister uneins darüber wie sie auf
eine mögliche russische aggression
reagieren sollen dass russland vom
internationalen zahlungssystem swift
ausgeschlossen werden könnte weiter
umstritten ich hatte ja bereits deutlich
gemacht dass der härteste knüppel nicht
immer das intelligenteste schwert am
ende sein wird sondern wir
finanzmaßnahmen so überprüfen müssen
dass sie die größte wirkung entfalten
behörden sanktionen müssen weh tun und
nur dann schrecken sie ab den sanktionen
nicht schmerzen sind sie keine
abschreckung um abschreckung geht es
auch den beiden außenministern von
finnland und schweden die am nachmittag
nato-generalsekretär stoltenberg treffen
obwohl sie keine nato mitglieder sind
angesichts der krise wollen sie die
zusammenarbeit mit der nato ausbauen
gleichzeitig kündigt das militärbündnis
an die präsenz in osteuropa zu
verstärken schiffe flugzeuge auch
kampfverbände sollen länder wie
bulgarien litauen und rumänien
unterstützen
wir haben unsere truppen aufgestockt
aber nur zu unserer verteidigung wir
bedrohen russland nicht unsere reaktion
ist angemessen die westlichen
bündnispartner rücken zusammen am abend
will us-präsident beiden per video
konferenz unter anderem mit kanzler
scholz dem französischen präsidenten und
den spitzen von nato und eu über den
konflikt mit russland beraten
enge absprachen also zwischen den
westlichen verbündeten dazu verstärkte
militärpräsenz der nato axel sturm wie
wird das in moskau aufgenommen
ja bis vor wenigen minuten gab es noch
kein offizielles statement dazu aber
ansonsten gibt man sich sehr sehr
selbstbewusst und ziemlich schroff auch
die situation ist ja der gestalt dass
man sich gegenseitig vorwürfe macht und
in russland heißt es nach wie vor ganz
deutlich eine invasion in die ukraine
sei weder geplant noch sei sie
realistisch der kreml sprecher ps kauf
sprach heute auch von einem in form von
einer informationssystem ii die sich im
westen breit mache die von lügen immer
wieder angefacht wurde also die lesart
hier in russland ist relativ eindeutig
der westen sei schuld an der
bedrohlichen situation und zwar und
nicht die 100.000 russischen soldaten im
grenzgebiet zur ukraine dank system über
die russische seite
der konflikt mit russland beunruhigt
viele menschen in der ukraine vor allem
die bewohner im osten des landes unserer
reporterin anna heißt es derzeit in der
millionenstadt aktiv sie berichtet von
menschen die mit sorge in die zukunft
schauen
archiv die zweitgrößte stadt in der
ukraine könnte die erste sein die von
den russen eingenommen wird sollte es
zum angriff kommen warnt der ukrainische
präsident zielinski die bewohner sind
überwiegend russisch sprach ich das
handelszentrum strategisch bedeutsam für
russen und separatisten die seit 2000 14
versuchen kontrolle über die region zu
bekommen er bereitet sich für den
ernstfall vor die metro will unerkannt
bleiben
ja ich arbeite für die verteidigungs
abteilung sollte die stadt besetzt
werden werde ich schläfer
als sogenannter schläfer soll die metro
dann unerkannt informationen sammeln für
das ukrainische militär nachfrage ob er
keine angst haben
natürlich aber die angst darf
wie dimitrow geht es vielen bürgern der
stadt eine befragung der bevölkerung hat
ergeben die mehrheit fürchtet den krieg
aber man sei bereit hart zu verteidigen
wenn es tatsächlich zum angriff der
russen kommen für den abgeordneten
dieser pro russischen partei sei dass
die falsche strategie er setzt auf
dialog mit russland und auf eine abkehr
von der nato
unseren westlichen partnern ist es
wichtig dass unser land unter fremden
einfluss bleibt es ist ihnen ganz egal
was hier passiert dabei besteht der
erfolg unseres landes in der engen
zusammenarbeit mit russland und mit
unseren nachbarländern
der erfolg unseres landes besteht nicht
darin den block status bei der nato zu
haben der wie ibm storage viele menschen
in hartz iv wünschen sich eine
friedliche lösung für ihre stadt doch
nicht um jeden preis
rund fünf monate ist es jetzt her dass
die taliban in afghanistan die macht
übernahmen seitdem gibt es dort immer
mehr hunger und not jetzt ist eine
delegation der radikalislamisten zu
verhandlungen ins ausland gereist
faustlos sprechen sie mit westlichen
diplomaten und diplomaten über die
angespannte lage drei tage lang und
hinter verschlossenen türen
wahrscheinlich werden die taliban auf
die freigabe von eingefrorenen
hilfsgeldern drängen von westlicher
seite steht die situation der frauen in
afghanistan
ganz oben auf der agenda
nach einem angriff der terror miliz es
auf ein gefängnis in nordsyrien dauern
die gefechte seit fünf tagen an
inzwischen wurden nach angaben der
syrischen beobachtungsstelle für
menschenrechte
mehr als 150 menschen getötet
seit tagen versuchen kurdische truppen
das gefängnis in der stadt ein hacker
wieder unter ihre kontrolle zu bringen
sie werden aus der luft von us truppen
unterstützt in dem gefängnis saßen
offenbar rund
3500 mutmaßliche ltte-kämpfer darunter
auch führer der miliz
trauer und entsetzen heute in heidelberg
ein amokläufer öffnet auf dem gelände
der universität das feuer tötete eine
frau verletzt drei weitere menschen
teils schwer oder schießt sich selbst
die tat ereignet sich am mittag in einem
hörsaal auf dem universitäts campus
neuenheimer feld der täter so heißt es
ist selbst student und einzeltäter eva
schiller berichtet der täter stürmte in
den vorlesungssaal schießt um sich gegen
13 uhr geht der erste notruf bei der
polizei ein es folgt ein großeinsatz am
uniklinikum heidelberg die lage zunächst
unübersichtlich berichten augenzeugen
wir wussten nicht wie die situation ist
nur wir haben bemerkt dass die polizei
so
die nerven grenzen waren so quasi es war
eher so eine schockstarre hatte ich das
gefühl es hat sich erst mal wenig getan
bis dann irgendwann auch ein polizist
meinte also wenn sie sich jetzt mich
weiter in gefahr begeben wollen dann
müssen sie jetzt sofort weg der täter
flüchtet in den botanischen garten dann
tötet er sich selbst
rettungskräfte bringen mehrere im
hörsaal schwer verletzte menschen in die
klinik dort soll eine frau an den
schussverletzungen gestorben sein die
polizei geht von einem einzeltäter aus
wir haben danach ein
spezialeinsatzkommando angefordert dass
hier das gesamte uni gelände abgesucht
hat nach einem zweiten täter wir gehen
allerdings von einem einzeltäter aus das
war reine sicherheitsmaßnahme kanzler
stolz zeigt sich bestürzt über den
amoklauf
es zerreißt mir das herz solch eine
nachricht zu erfahren wenn dabei das bei
den angehörigen und den opfern und
natürlich bei den studentinnen und
studenten der universität halle das
motiv der tat ist bislang unklar
augenzeugen zufolge soll der mann selbst
student gewesen sein die geschockten
studierenden und die angehörigen der
opfer werden jetzt von seelsorgern
betreut
und soeben hat eine pressekonferenz zum
amoklauf begonnen antonia nähe
beobachtet sie für uns anton was es über
den täter und die tat neues bekannt
es gibt noch nichts neues über den täter
und auch nicht über die tat über die
hintergründe das sind alles dinge die
die polizei jetzt ermitteln möchte wir
sind noch in einem frühen stadium der
ermittlungen hat der leitende
staatsanwalt gesagt es ist ein
fürchterlicher tag für uns alle damit
hat es der oberbürgermeister von
heidelberg auf den punkt gebracht eine
schreckliche tat mit einer toten und
drei schwerverletzten
die tat die sehr an den amoklauf 2009 in
winnenden erinnert bei dem 15
jugendliche kinder ums leben gekommen
sind es ist jetzt viel arbeit für die
polizei zu ergründen was hinter diesem
amoklauf steckt wir werden die nächsten
tage sicherlich einiges zu berichten
haben darüber vielen dank an toni an
über den stand der dinge zur zeit danke
jetzt ein kurzer blick nach burkina faso
den meuternde soldaten sollen den dort
amtierenden präsidenten und
regierungsmitglieder in ihre gewalt
gebracht haben die westafrikanische
staatengemeinschaft spricht von einem
putschversuch burkina faso kämpft wie
das angrenzende mal die seit jahren mit
radikalislamischen milizen präsident
kaboré hatte versprochen das
blutvergießen zu stoppen viele seiner
soldaten fühlen sich aber alleine
gelassen die nachricht heute von der
gefangennahme cabarets wurde auf den
straßen gefeiert und gerade eben sollen
die militärs im fernsehen machtübernahme
verkündet haben
bei uns schneit es fast nirgendwo
deutschland liegt derzeit eingeklemmt
zwischen hoch- und tiefdruckgebieten das
ganz anders erleben die menschen in
südosteuropa das ganze die wetterlage
bei dem kontinent schaufelte reichlich
kalte luft aus dem norden in die türkei
und nach griechenland
in der hauptstadt athen blieben die
schulen geschlossen und sommerurlaub ist
an den stränden gefühlt noch ganz weit
weg
und jetzt kommen wir zur handball
europameisterschaft norbert uns zum aus
wie die deutsche mannschaft nach der
niederlage gestern abend gegen schweden
hat das dhb team keine chance mehr aufs
halbfinale dennoch will die mannschaft
morgen im letzten hauptrundenspiel gegen
russland noch mal alles geben und segen
trotz weiterer corona verleben team
man kommt allmählich mit dem zählen
nicht mehr nach simon ernst und patrick
wiencek die korona fälle 14 und 15 im
deutschen team auch die zwei haben das
hotel in bratislava bereits wieder
richtung deutschland verlassen
stand heute auch bei denen
die es neu dazu gekommen sind momentan
kein
syndrom so dass er sagen würde das ist
irgendwie für ihn persönlich auch
medizinisch kaum zu ertragen die
niederlage gegen den wm zweiten schweden
ärgerlich weil vielleicht mit weniger
flüchtigkeitsfehlern mehr drin gewesen
wäre bei manch einem war der frust aber
schnell verflogen nächste desto trotz
komisches spiel abwarten ich hab dann
football geguckt und das war dann so
spannend dass ich da nicht mehr drüber
nachdenken musste auch bundestrainer
alfred gislasson nimmt das ganze wie wir
beim abschluss training gesehen haben
mit galgenhumor
gestern abend american football ein
dramatisches playoff die knappe 27 30
niederlage von titelverteidiger tampa
bay buccaneers gegen die los angeles
times die möglicherweise das
karriereende von superstar tom brady
zufolge hat
war dass sein letzter auftritt tom brady
44 jahre rekordhalter mit sieben super
bowl siegen gestoppt in einem überaus
dramatischen spiel proben seines könnens
gab der quarterback der tampa bay
buccaneers erst in der schlussphase ab
dann aber waren sie von überragender
klasse ein touchdown-pass zum 20 27
tampa hatte schon drei zu 27
zurückgelegen eine finte mit
anschließendem fieldgoal zum nicht mehr
für möglich gehaltenen ausgleich kurz
vor schluss 27 beide doch mitten hinein
in die euphorie dieser langen ball der
ems und die chance mit der schlusssirene
entscheidende drei punkte zu holen durch
ein fieldgoal
spezialist mexiko tiert los angeles
träumt vom super bowl tom brady traum
geplatzt ob er weitermacht lässt er
vorerst offen
das war es auch schon boxsport
dankeschön hat noch kurz zum wetter
ruhiges winterwetter begleitet uns auch
in den nächsten tagen man sich daran
etwas ändert das erfahren sie gleich von
katja hall war das heute journal können
sie um 22 45 sehen mit marietta slomka
und die geht es gleich weiter mit einem
zdf spezial
[Musik]